Now, let's wrap up our course with some resources that you may find helpful when working with
metahumans.
When rendering image sequences with metahumans, the following console variables can assist
with high quality renders.
Feel free to take a snapshot of these.
You do not have to use all of them at the same time, as they each have their own use,
which depends on several factors.
For example, the Hairstrands Holdout Mode console variable can be helpful if using Movie Render
Graph.
This will apply the Hairstrand separation to the Holdout node for creating better alpha
layers for compositing.
Finally, all of the resources and links to some of the tools discussed today can be found
by following the URLs on this slide.
Feel free to pause here or take a screenshot for later reference.
This brings us to the end of the Metahuman Blueprints and Animation course.
I want to thank you for spending your time with me, and I hope these videos help you
as you continue working with metahumans in Unreal Engine.